This has been my favorite late night snack lately.
Just hear me out. We do a scoop of vanilla ice cream.
Sometimes I do two scoops or three.
Then we take some good quality olive oil,
put some on top. This is what I've been having the past few nights.
I made this cherry compote that is so good.
It's just cooked down cherries with some lemon juice
and a little bit of maple syrup.
I broke them up, and I'm left with this beautiful compote.
Put some of that on top. I also make sure that it's a little warm.
It's just good if it's warm with the vanilla ice cream.
Then we take some good quality,
flaky sea salt. It doesn't have to be a lot,
just a pinch on top. Oh,
my goodness. This looks so good.
There's something about the olive oil and the vanilla ice cream
and then the sweetness of the cherry,
but the crunch of the salt. This is so good.
Yes.